one two three ready
pfizer and biontech have asked u.s
health regulators to authorize their
covid19 vaccine for children 5 to 11
years old the fda may clear the shot for
use in that age group before november
which could mean pediatrician offices
schools and pharmacies are able to begin
distributing doses between halloween and
thanksgiving this news is welcomed by
many parents of vaccine ineligible
children who have watched nervously as
schools reopened and pediatric coveted
19 cases rose fueled by the highly
contagious delta variant
in the first week of october there were
nearly 150 000 new child covet 19 cases
reported in the u.s which accounted for
almost a quarter of total new cases
reported nationwide public health
experts say vaccinating children is
crucial to protecting them from
infection and achieving community-wide
immunity but the percentage of
vaccine-eligible children who are fully
vaccinated lags behind adults many
parents of children who are still
ineligible say they will vaccinate their
children as soon as the shot is
authorized but other parents are
hesitant sometimes even when they've
been vaccinated themselves if i would do
it to myself
why isn't it good enough for my daughter
but then you kind of bring in all of
those parental aspects of wanting to
protect them and do the right thing and
possible guilt if there's vaccine injury
and all of the unknowns and you just get
kind of thrown back into this whirlwind
of oh my gosh what what is the right
decision here a recent survey by the
kaiser family foundation found that if
authorized 34 of parents said they'd
vaccinate their five to 11 year old kids
right away while 32 said they would wait
and see i do think that maybe not being
the first in line and allowing um other
children to go first who want to be
first in line
you know once vaccines are given to a
mass population will then probably have
a lot more
real life data on how it affects our
children i think it's a incredibly
natural
human instinct to protect our children
and i think sometimes
in things that there are questions or if
there's unknowns it's a little bit
easier for us to
take that risks with ourselves than it
is with our with our babies with our
children i think it's important to to
remember that there are
many many known risks to covet
infections the risks of vaccines are far
more theoretical kathy who is vaccinated
says she'd like to see more data from
the trials before coming to a decision
on vaccinating her eight-year-old
daughter i believe in science i believe
that the facts are there um i do
however wish that the data from the
trials was more
more available to the public and also
sort of in layman's terms as opposed to
being
hard data to process and really sort
through yourself
with the potential authorization of
pfizer's vaccine in younger children on
the horizon pediatricians across the
country are working to share information
about the vaccine with parents one
challenge they say is that the public
health message over the last year has
been that kids usually don't get very
sick from the virus dr gamble says there
are three main points that she tries to
hit during conversations with families
the first thing to remember is that we
know the vaccine works from studies in
adults we know that the vaccine helps
prevent disease and we also know that
vaccinated individuals that do catch
covid are far less likely to suffer from
severe complications or to die i have
every reason to believe that the vaccine
will be just as effective in kids the
second reason is that we know children
spread the virus that causes copin 19
disease even children that have no
symptoms can spread covid19 and the
vaccine helps decrease this spread the
third consideration is really thinking
about the broader impact that this
pandemic has had on kids mental health
and well-being every single day i'm
seeing the physical and emotional
manifestations of chronic stress on our
children pediatricians say a common
question they hear from parents is about
the possibility of unknown long-term
side effects from the vaccine because
it's new that's not a question that i
haven't heard before the pneumococcal
vaccine the vaccine to prevent
hemophilus influenza type b chickenpox
vaccine were all vaccines that i've seen
developed in my career and those
questions came up before and the answer
today is what it was then the studies
that we've done to look at this vaccine
has shown that it is safe and there's no
expectation of anything happening long
term with those other three vaccines
that has proven to be true the
population of children that i'm actually
immunizing now are the children of those
people that i immunize for the first
time with some of those uh particular
vaccines and so i can point to them when
i see that mother that i took care of as
a child and say you you came out okay
dr patterson says he's also worked to
ally specific concerns about fertility
myocarditis and pericarditis by sharing
data and research with families
continuing to help them understand
how science is uh paying attention to
side effects how we are uh capturing
potential problem areas and how we are
really making a difference in the
outcome that people are having those are
some of the ways to convince or
encourage those who take the wait and
see approach
that that now is the time should the fda
greenlight the vaccine for young
children they would get two injections
three weeks apart like adolescents and
adults but at a lower dosage after the
authorization in 5 to 11 year olds the
only group left awaiting vaccines will
be children as young as 6 months pfizer
has said that results from a study in
younger children ages 6 months to under
5 years could come towards the end of
2021